[Music]
on this thursday night another mission
to stop sexual misconduct in canada's
military
the latest review who will conduct it
what will it cover and
what's being promised this time i'm
truly sorry
fresh injection of hope promising news
about canada's vaccine rollout
a potential solution ignored why some
long-term care homes were not held
accountable
for their failures plus they are loud
and messy i've been squirted by these
things trillions of these creepy
crawlers are emerging
a story that could bug you
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
after decades of failing to deal with
allegations of sexual misconduct in the
military
allegations that now reach the highest
levels there is
another plan to root it out and stop it
louise arbor former supreme
court justice and former u.n high
commissioner for human rights
will lead an independent external review
of the military's handling of sexual
harassment and misconduct
it is the second review in six years
today as
defense minister harjit sajun announced
it he also
apologized to every member in the
canadian armed forces
to every person in the department of
national defense who has been affected
by sexual harassment
and violence and felt that we were not
there to support you
i'm truly sorry for too long critics say
the military has protected
its own sajin says the focus needs to
shift to those who've experienced
misconduct and harassment including
a reporting system outside the chain of
command it
is not a new idea it's just never been
implemented before
the military has also promoted a woman
to a new role to oversee conduct and
professionalism
it's not clear though what power she
actually has
after the last review general vance
himself promised changes he is now
under investigation himself our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stephenson has
been driving the coverage on this story
and has our top story tonight
in early february allegations of sexual
misconduct against the military's former
top soldier general jonathan vance
stunned the country and the forces that
single story
triggered an avalanche a reckoning in
the military as victims came forward
the hardest part is knowing there's
nowhere to turn to we don't have a seat
at the table
we're not getting justice the liberal
government has come under fire
the prime minister's chief of staff and
the defense minister
were both aware of allegations against
vance in 2018.
the self-styled feminist government
failed to implement
key recommendations from the landmark
deschamps report
into military misconduct in 2015. it all
made madame
louise arbor dubious of the value of yet
another report when the government came
calling
my first reaction was well just as the
sun was there
when was it it seemed just a few years
ago but how many times is going to take
to look at this ultimately mata marbour
concluded a renewed and broader review
of military sexual misconduct was needed
arbor says trust has been undermined in
the forces
and operational effectiveness is at risk
maybe
six years later this might be the
opportunity to actually
put it right her review will look into
the force's promotion system that
enabled toxic leadership
the military justice system victims say
has failed them and an
external independent reporting mechanism
outside the chain of command
we have heard you we have listened
and we are taking action the promise
changes include a culture czar who will
review the armed forces policies
but there's little detail on what newly
minted lieutenant general karina will do
what powers that will be determined in
the next few weeks
as we are confirming and working a clear
mandate
victims of military sexual assault like
leo west say the government has known
about the need for external reporting
for years
and it should have been announced today
it should have happened
then it has not and that
is a failure i think of leadership on
behalf of the minister of national
defense and of the
of the tudor government mercedes you
broke the story about sexual misconduct
allegations against the former chief of
the defense staff general jonathan vance
that is in large part what spurred this
renewed focus on what is a long-standing
problem in the military
is this new external review going to
look at the allegations
against vance donna it will not
look at the allegations against vance
and i have that directly from madame
arbor herself when i talked to her this
afternoon
she said she will be looking at systemic
issues in culture
but not specific cases that leaves that
case in the hands of military police
and the military justice system areas
that victims have raised concerns about
as to whether or not the system could
lay charges or could
actually carry out a trial if those
charges are laid
ultimately victims remain skeptical but
hopeful donna okay mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thank you
now to news about cobit 19 vaccines here
is where
canada is at with the rollout 31.5
percent of canadians
have now received at least one dose that
is more than 11.9 million
people just 2.9 percent of canadians
though are
fully vaccinated with two shots the
vaccine rollout is
gaining momentum today canada's two
largest provinces announced everyone 18
years and older
will have access to their first dose
within the next month
it's encouraging news with the risk of
infection at its highest point right now
and as heather urex west reports
unvaccinated essential workers are
wondering
if it's finally their turn
for workers at the cargill meat packing
plant in high river alberta
the last year has been tough i would get
scared
very very often and i don't want to see
my entire family go down with something
just because of the place that i work
last spring nearly half of the plant's
2200 workers became ill with covet 19.
since then there have been several more
smaller outbreaks here too
it's why this long-awaited vaccine
clinic means
so much i'm going to get vaccinated
today and we're all going to get
vaccinated today today is going to be a
good day
but across canada many essential workers
are still
waiting for their turn to be called
teachers and
child care providers and construction
workers and postal workers and
all these essential workers who are
reaching out and saying that they're
desperate
and they're not on the list that's
because outside of bc
vaccine priority has mainly come with
age
but very soon canada's two largest
provinces believe
they'll have enough vaccine for everyone
we have announced that we are opening
tomorrow
the the vaccination for the
population in general based on current
supply projections the quebec government
expects the vaccine will be made
available
to everyone 18 and older by may 14th
may 24th in ontario this is
exciting news the way out of the
pandemic is vaccines
and the light at the end of the tunnel
grows brighter every day
the provincial promise made possible by
the increases in supply
starting next week canada will receive 2
million weekly doses of the pfizer
biontech vaccine
ramping up to 2.4 million a week in june
while 300 000 doses of johnson and
johnson are in the process of
thawing out before they distributed once
shipments are repackaged
deliveries will start the provinces and
this is expected at the beginning of
next week
each dose representing priceless peace
of mind
protection after so many months living
in fear
heather urex west global news calgary
the family of a quebec woman who
developed rare blood clots and died
after receiving the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine is urging others to watch for
symptoms and seek medical treatment
right away
54 year old francine boye died on april
23
two weeks after receiving the first
astrazeneca dose in a statement written
in french her family says she
experienced headaches and fatigue in the
days after the vaccine and
was taken to the nearest hospital her
condition deteriorated
and she was transferred to the montreal
neurological hospital institute
she died of cerebral thrombosis she is
the only person in canada known to have
died as a result of a covet vaccine
six other canadians have been treated
for blood clots the blood clots are
extremely rare events the risk of
getting a blood clot from a covid19
infection is about 10 times greater
than getting a blood clot from the
vaccine
there is some cautious optimism in
ontario new modeling shows the third
wave is now cresting because of the
latest public health restrictions
and more vaccinations though case
numbers are dropping faster than was
originally projected
they are nowhere near as low as they
need to be the modeling shows if
transmission levels remained where they
are
today daily case numbers in ontario
would still be above
2000 new infections per day by the end
of may
and there would still be the potential
for cases to rise again
starting a fourth wave
many countries and jurisdictions have
been here before
it's tempting to relax when the numbers
start to turn your way
but it will not work this is the time to
commit to getting them down
tomorrow is the deadline for a
commission looking into what went wrong
in ontario long-term care homes during
the pandemic to issue its report to
government
among its interim findings a ministry
inspection system that
lacks enforcement and verification that
violations are actually addressed the
same issues with inspections were
highlighted yesterday in ontario's
auditor general report
as carolyn jarvis reports a potential
solution was on the table before covet
19
struck but was never used
inspectors knew that this would be a
problem someday and it happened
watching the death toll rise as care
homes buckled under the weight of
coveted 19
has been agonizing for this former
long-term care home inspector
whose identity we've agreed to conceal
because they still work in the industry
it's absolutely devastating because you
knew that these problems were inherent
and that the homes were not prepared and
they were not prepared to respond
adequately to it
more than 3 700 residents of long-term
care homes in ontario
have died since covid struck some homes
with long lists of inspection violations
both before
and during the pandemic you look at
things like inspections that have been
done
in the midst of outbreaks they've shown
gross deficiencies
but how has that information been acted
upon and how have the inspectors gone
back
in a timely manner to ensure that those
deficiencies were rectified so that
we're protecting the residents
part of the reason little was done some
speculate is that penalties
are rarely imposed and there are no
financial consequences
inspectors don't have a lot of teeth i
can tell you to do something and you can
do the bare minimum to meet it but
there's no penalty towards it
under the previous liberal provincial
government a bill was passed to give
inspectors the power to issue an
administrative penalty
but an election was called and it was
never enacted
doug ford's provincial government could
have moved forward with the law
but says it wanted to do more
consultation and so fines
never happened we say that the
government has
an oversight mechanism that failed
miserably long before covet
daryl singer is one of the lawyers
behind a proposed class action lawsuit
against dozens of long-term care homes
in ontario where outbreaks occurred
it alleges the provincial government is
also liable
for a lack of enforcement what would
happen if the police were pulling people
over
giving speeding tickets but there was no
follow-up would you pay your ticket
no of course you wouldn't and that's
exactly what's happened with the nursing
homes
there's no consequence the government
says it's still considering other
enforcement options
and in the meantime we'll continue to
use management orders
to help homes in need carolyn jarvis
global news
toronto
we'll have more on our investigation
into long-term care homes in ontario and
whether they heated warnings this
saturday at 7 on the new reality
right here on global the federal
government
is giving emergency aid to another
canadian airline it has agreed to give
air transit up to 700 million dollars in
repayable loans
as a condition nearly half of the money
will be used to refund travelers for
cancelled flights
reimbursements for customers who were
scheduled to leave on or after february
1st of 2020
are expected to begin immediately air
transat will also issue ottawa 13
million warrants for the purchase of
company
shares at four dollars and fifty cents
each the loan is from the same program
that was used earlier this month to help
air canada the world's worst covid19
outbreak with no relief in sight coming
up the tragedy in
india's hospitals and streets
it was long ago india thought it had
come through the pandemic relatively
unscathed now people are dying in their
homes
and other people are begging to be
treated inside overflowing hospitals
loved ones are doing anything they can
to try and save those who are fighting
to breathe
international aid is arriving in the
country but as crystal gamansing
explains it won't be enough to change
what's happening
right now and a warning you may find
some of the images
in her story disturbing
at this hospital in delhi there's no
physical distancing no
special barrier separating covet 19
patients
and no certainty treatment will continue
this obstacle can be switched off at any
time if it is not available
then what will i do i will just see him
dying in front of me
thursday saw the highest daily death
toll since the start of the pandemic
and those are only the officially
registered deaths
one icu doctor says what he is
witnessing in his hospital
is beyond a crisis they are dying on the
way to the hospital because they're
going from hospital to hospital trying
to find a bed
that's no way to treat arthritis
desperate cries can be heard inside
hospitals
and out on the streets every single day
i hear
my friends family uh getting infected
and people losing their my you know
numbers and names now fatima sings
younger sister
tested positive an added stressor for
sing as she works to organize red cross
efforts on the ground
currently they are ensuring you know
working
closely with the local administration
working in
ambulance services and blood services
first aid oxygen supplies
supplies are arriving daily but the need
is immense india is the second
most populous nation and the virus is
raging different cities and regions have
lockdowns such as delhi and
many people are staying home others
have no choice they're needed at work
crystal gamansen global news london
still ahead president biden's bold
promises to transform america
u.s president joe biden has touched down
in atlanta to sell the bold plans he
laid out in last night's speech to
congress
biden said trickle-down economics has
never worked and that the economy has to
grow from
the bottom and middle out hello
georgia in the other county back there
i love you a lot of folks out here
tonight if you ever wonder
if elections make a difference just
remember what you did here in georgia
when you elected ossoff and warnock
you begin to change the environment
[Music]
the president is proposing trillions in
new spending and expansive new social
programs
jackson proskow reports on biden's plans
and whether he can deliver them
the president of the united states
believing
this is the moment america is ready for
change president joe biden outlined an
unprecedented plan to remake the country
we have to prove democracy still works
that our government still works and we
can deliver
for our people using his slim
progressive majority in congress
biden wants to expand the role of
government calling for six trillion
dollars in new spending
paid for with tax hikes on the super
rich proposing things rarely spoken of
in the u.s
like universal pre-kindergarten paid
leave
and free tuition at community colleges
trickle down economics has never worked
it's time to grow the economy from the
bottom in the middle out
republicans who supported big deficits
during the trump years
are now clutching their wallets claiming
the proposals are too expensive or too
alarming
at least one appeared to doze off during
biden's address
joe is deliberately being boring but the
substance of what he's saying is
radical i think that by being more
mild-mannered
and than his predecessor it's not only
what the american people want but it
also helps to lower
uh the volume on capitol hill and helps
people to work together
not that biden needs to work with anyone
he seems to be daring his opponents to
vote against the things he believes
voters want
the president recently signed a two
trillion dollar covet relief bill
not a single republican voted for it
polls show
two-thirds of americans approve the bill
when they talk about unity
they're talking about delivering for the
american people writ large
they're not talking necessarily about
playing nicely with the republicans in
congress if they can't get what they
want
biden's own approval rating sits at 57
percent
less popular than obama at 100 days far
more popular than trump ever was
but perhaps popular enough to make these
once-in-a-generation changes
thank you jackson prosko global news
washington
the u.s has imposed sanctions on russia
and said there will be consequences if
jailed opposition leader alexi navalny
dies in prison
today he appeared in a court hearing by
video link the first time he's been seen
since his three-week hunger strike
looking gaunt navalny denounced the
russian president vladimir putin as an
emperor with no clothes
the judge upheld navalny's conviction
for defamation he was jailed in february
in a separate case for breaking parole
the 44 year old went on a hunger strike
to demand access to his own doctors he
says
his supporters say the charges are
trumped up and they accuse putin of
being behind an attempt
to poison him to death
bug party next the noisy species
emerging
for a mass gathering
something record-breaking is expected to
emerge from underground this year
after 17 years spent buried in dirt
trillions of cicadas will surface on
mass
cicadas won't hurt you they don't sting
and they're not venomous
but they have other ways of making their
presence felt and heard
as mike trolley explains
if you have a phobia of bugs you may
want to close your eyes
because after 17 years the periodical
family of cicadas known as brood 10
have begun to emerge from the ground
like the undead in a horror movie
some call it one of the seven wonders of
the insect world
biologist gene kritsky who wrote the
actual book on brood 10
is in cicada heaven they are rather
attractive but
you gotta remember they got me tenure so
i'm somewhat biased for the next four to
six weeks you'll be tracking their
emergence with the help of an app called
cicada safari finding them won't be a
problem
they number in the billions and their
mating call can be louder than a jet
engine
and then there's the ick factor they
shed their husks
among other things they're piercing
sucking insects they can
and they feed on tree roots now i have
seen
males squirt i've been squirted by these
things
kritsky describes it like standing in a
light rain
but unless you're a entomologist
specifically studying
cicada rain it's best to avoid it
the good news is brewed 10 will appear
only in the u.s
canada has its own periodical and annual
broods they're significantly smaller and
quieter
but no less interesting for the most
part people
are won't say encourage more
ambivalent about insects and
if not direct animosity so to have
something that that engages
them in a in a positive way i i think is
is a really good thing
cicadas might not be for everyone but
there's no point in complaining about
brood 10
who's going to hear you micro lake
global news
toronto
put me in the ambivalent category that
is global national for this thursday i'm
donna friesen
tonight's your canada is solely cove
near five islands nova scotia
thanks for watching i'll see you on
saturday for the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye